ramsey show you can be intentional about
your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the
youtube
very popular show called the table is my
co-host today
we're here to help you and talk to you
about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two
five five two two
five so anthony forbes is reporting
this and anthony by the way number one
best-selling book
debt free degree
which apparently a lot of people didn't
get the book or the idea
right uh because the student loan crisis
is at epic
proportions according to the washington
post president joe biden will not
include any student loan cancellation in
his annual budget
while the annual budget which is
expected at the end of the next week
only contains major policy plans that
have already been released
by the biden administration it's another
major setback for
student loan cancellation as a
presidential candidate biden called for
congress to cancel up to ten thousand
dollars of student loans for student
loan borrowers
but hasn't enacted any policy for
student loan cancellation
through an executive order the exclusion
of student loan cancellation isn't a
surprise
based on the latest news on student loan
cancellation it's easier to read the
writing on the wall about where biden
stands on his executive authority
to cancel student loans it's not that
biden doesn't support
student loan cancellation he does
however biden wants congress
not the president to enact student loan
cancellation
through legislation
so turns out um and and you know
that there's no we used to say things
when i was a kid anthony see if you've
ever heard this saying
that's like an act of congress
which means it's impossible right yeah
you know you can't get you take forever
and if you do
if you do get you know that's why it's
easier to get an act of congress
people say my i've heard people say that
my whole life and so
um now biden is saying it but um
yeah so the uh you know the problem
though is that people quit paying their
student loans because they think that
aoc and biden is going to come and
elizabeth warren is going to come save
them
yeah and so the default rate on student
loans have gone way up because they're
all anticipating a
forgiveness a political uh some kind of
a political
activity to forgive their loans it
appears
if it does happen it's not gonna be
anytime soon and i think the thing that
is so discouraging for me dave is
i've been criticized on my show telling
people take advantage of paying off your
student loans
because you're not you're not gaining
any interest right now but the number
one
critique that i'm getting from people is
well wait i want to see what biden is
going to do with counseling the student
loans
and now look we get this we get this
like biden is not going to fight for it
and i believe now dave i could be wrong
let me say this on the
on the ramp so i could be wrong but i do
not see congress
coming in and making it happen now it
could happen but
history is showing us that it's not
going to happen
well it could happen um
but one thing's for sure not anytime
soon
that we can count on yeah because it
requires an act of congress
right and so uh it's not gonna you know
so
the problem with this is this is where
piss-poor leadership
yeah sends a signal that causes people
to engage in self-destructive behaviors
yeah yeah
meaning i'm not gonna pay my student
loans because the government's going to
let me out of them
and so now i'm in default and default by
the way screws up your credit
by the way it builds up late fees and
interest and penalties
and by the way it's going to make it
harder for you to get out
and by the way most of you owe more than
ten thousand dollars
yeah yeah the average owes about thirty
eight thousand
that's the average nationally and we
talk to people on here every day with
over a hundred
absolutely um the i think the thing is
this folks
what you really need to get your head
around from an economics perspective not
a political
perspective not a moral or philosophical
you know is it your right to have your
student loan forgiven is it
philosophically
all of that really doesn't matter here's
a real practical fact for you
the government is not good at
anything definitely they're not
efficient
at anything and so anytime
anywhere in your life you are waiting on
them
to fix your life your life is going to
continue to suck
yes it's a simple principle of life yeah
yeah you know if if anybody wearing a
superman cape with an
r or a d on it is flying across
in your vision promising you that your
life is going to be okay
and you believe them when they do that
you
are screwed now dave would you agree
uh if i said hey listen keep
riding your path keep paying your
student loan student loans keep doing it
and if congress comes in
and says i'll forgive 10 000 then you
take it but if they don't you're still
moving forward
i wouldn't say not to take it there you
go you know if it comes
but i would not adjust your current life
and your current plan
based on false promises coming out of
washington d.c
because they've been coming out of
washington dc as long as it has been
there
yes yeah and so you're i'm
old a hundred percent of my success has
been
the blessings of the lord yeah customers
that loved how we served them
and my heart but work yeah i have not
gotten
any money from washington dc they have
not sent me
any money i'm not waiting on them to
create
a successful life for dave ramsey
and if you wait on them to create a
successful life for you
your life's going to continue to suck
yeah the same thing when you're waiting
on
i'm waiting on biden bucks to come in
the stimulus money if 600 dollars
changes your life your life was already
messed up baby
you were already playing small ball you
weren't playing big
it's t-ball you know so you need to get
you get in
where they're throwing fast pitches and
swing for the fence honey if you want to
be
you got to play big you got to think big
and you know you're playing small ball
when you're
when you're looking for the government
to bail you out of anything now if
they start handing me some of the money
i have paid them back in any form or
format
i agree i will take that now when i take
it it's a different kind of criticism
than you get when you talk about this
yeah if i take it it's called corporate
welfare
oh lord corporate welfare oh no that was
me getting some of my money back
that's what that was so any challenge i
can get my corporate welfare i'll be
signing up for that but
but i am not waiting and i'm not
adjusting my success patterns
the behaviors in my life to uh wait on
the government to fix
my life i'm not going to let them
influence me into violating common sense
in order to do that and that's what you
have is another failed political promise
right here absolutely
so tomorrow sorry america is pay off
your dadgum student loans go after it
and if they give you some money use it
use it wisely but until then
if they do not pay your bills bottom
line
as fast as you can yeah the secret
to million becoming a millionaire is not
waiting on the government to do it for
you
oh wow that was insightful
who thought of that i did
[Music]
destroy your student loans if you want
to do that there's a book by anthony
o'neill at ramseysolutions.com right now
that'll really get you out of debt but
we're not paying any of it for you
darling you're going to pay it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony we could do student loan
forgiveness we could just say
i forgive you
i was about to say wait where are you
going with this day
it's worth about what when one of the
politicians says it right
it's about as good it's about as useful
wow i forgive you
wow dave i've got student loans i
forgive you oh yeah
you just made somebody upset listening
right now you know it's i've been doing
that for 30 years it's a spiritual gift
all right sarah's with us in raleigh
north carolina hey sarah welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call my pleasure
how can we help
so um we just recently heard about your
plan in this last year and we've worked
really hard
and we've got rid of 20 000 in credit
card debt and have about 6 000 left
the problem is is that um recently well
about ten years ago
my in-laws gave us ten thousand dollars
when we were getting out of medical
school
and my husband was um going to get his
first job and we're moving across the
country
and they said okay just pay this back
whenever you have it it's not a big deal
well
recently we offended them and they want
their ten thousand dollars back
so we don't have they didn't let's
rephrase this
when someone says give it back to me
later
that's not a gift that's a loan
okay right you just pay us back whenever
no big deal
right that's a loan
isn't it right yeah they loaned you
money
and uh so uh but it just didn't have
really good clarity and good
communication in good terms there was no
date certain no interest rate no
payment rate nothing it was just you
know pay us back someday when you can
yeah right right yes okay and how many
years ago was this
10 10 years and you told me that and i
already forgot already
and so uh your household income now is
what
it's about 150. and you have six
thousand dollars left plus this ten
right um yes of all we have a mortgage
and we have a car payment
oh car payment is part of the debt
snowball hunt so
six thousand dollars plus a car what do
you owe in your car
um we it's around thirty thousand
okay all right so you have thirty six
thousand forty six thousand dollars in
debt and you make a hundred and fifty
yeah
yes how much do you have in your savings
right now
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay okay sarah hold on i got this
dave i got this dave
so sarah when we asked this question on
how much debt did you have that's
everything excluding a mortgage okay so
you're new to us so i want to step in
before you know
you know uncle dave comes in uh so your
brother
is going to come in and help you out
here so how much debt do you have
excluding your mortgage right now all
together
okay so um 6 000
um credit card 30 000 the car payment
and about 100 000 in student loans
we went from six thousand america to 136
thousand dollars in debt
forty six years a hundred brother in law
yeah uh huh
goodness gracious okay so here's the
thing that and i'm going to say this too
because you're just starting off with
this you're going to work the debt
snowball and you're going to put the ten
thousand dollars inside of that debt
snowball
so you think she ought to pay him back i
mean well if it was a loan
yeah did it sound like to you she said
give it back to us later
that's a loan to me okay i'm just making
sure we heard the same thing
okay am i wrong no no no i'm just just
checking
you know checking in with you i mean i
wish you could see you're running around
since you're running interference here i
thought i'd check it out
uncle dave over here looking at you know
brother day i mean anthony over here
like
what you're thinking um but yeah i think
you need to add that in there
until so to answer your direct question
yes you need to pay it back
um and i think
family owing family money compared to
owing a bank money
is worse in my opinion because it just
creates so much more drama
and so i want you to get to it as much
as possible
um as quick as possible but what is the
uh
six thousand dollar debt yeah
that's six what is that that's a
it's a um normal credit card
the low rate okay and then you have
another thirty thousand on a
one single credit card no that's a car
that's the car yeah that's right okay
good okay all right cool so our debt
snowball sarah that we teach the fastest
most efficient way to get out of debt is
list your debts
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and attack them in that
order do you all have any money in
savings that is not
retirement i bet you they do um
we have a roth ira
no how much money do you have in your
checking account right now
um about ten thousand
okay that's a pretty good bit all right
so what would i do
if i woke up in your shoes today is how
we answer questions here
knowing what i know of 30 years of
teaching people to become wealthy
the shortest distance between you and
wealth is to be debt-free
before not counting your mortgage as
soon as possible
because if you had no payments making
150 000 you'd have some money agreed
right okay so we're going to list the
debts smallest to largest and attack
them out order today i'm going to write
a check and pay off the six thousand
dollar credit card
by the way you need to cut it up and
close it
and only use a debit card you can't get
out of that while you continually go
back in
okay yeah and we're well on our way for
that one i think thing number two
is you're gonna as soon as possible in
the next two months
write a check and pay off your in-laws
now
okay here's the problem
the only reason they want the money back
now is they're trying to punish you
because you didn't mind
them right they told you to do something
and it offended them right
what was it well
um because we've kind of seen a pattern
of behavior
they wanted to move to the same town
with us
and we said that we didn't think that
was a good idea
so they were very very upset
yeah that would hurt them so what was
the point what's the pattern of behavior
um just that they get offended very
quickly and easily over small things
and we were like if you're living right
next to us they're gonna
you know they're gonna be upset at us
for this or that and
things like this are gonna happen for
the rest of our lives for their life
so we go ahead and give them a big thing
to be offended at like don't move to my
town
that's not a little one that's a big one
okay yeah that would hurt most people's
feelings so
you've already drawn some uncomfortable
boundaries with them
um that you felt were necessary uh
and i'm not saying they weren't but um
so you telling them when you're gonna
pay back a loan
that you choose to pay back on a moral
ground
not a legal ground because they have no
legal standing in this at all
this was a handshake yeah okay right
so you get to choose the terms
okay uh so in other words no you don't
get to choose to punish me by doing this
but i will honor your request and repay
the loan
on my terms you don't have to say it
that way but you just take that stand
and your terms happen to be that it's
the next thing
on your list of things to do since you
paid off your credit card today okay
and then you're gonna save up real quick
like i mean one month or two months and
you're gonna write
one check for ten thousand dollars and
be sure in the four column
to put paid in full
that just says another message for them
to be offended about but just in case
in case they decide to come back and go
now we want interest or whatever
because this is all they're getting
right and they're not getting
anything else so
because i'm not having you pay them back
because their feelings are hurt
i'm having them pay i'm having you pay
them back because you were
obligated to do that morally anyway when
you took the money
it was alone and we're all in agreement
on that are we not sarah
yes yeah even though you don't really
want to because they're
instituting this on pure punishment and
they're being childish
i don't blame you for those feelings but
i'm executing i'm executing on principle
here
and on mathematics and let's just go
ahead and get this out of the way oh and
by the way now you're free the
borrower's slave to the lender
and you're not anymore beholden and so
now you can be kind and strong
and gentle with them and continue to set
appropriate boundaries
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over dollars a
month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree is my co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
now on the debt-free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions stephen is with us
hey stephen how are you
good how about yourself better than i
deserve brother where do you live
charlotte north carolina oh beautiful
town very cool
and all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream that's it
love it how much have you paid off
eighty-nine thousand dollars
love it how long did this take it took
me 364 days
oh he beat the year just i had a year so
that helped
i love it i love it and your range of
income during this year
it was uh starting at 79 and went up to
94.
good for you and i had a a 20 000 gift
from my uncle
very nice what do you do for a living
i'm a technology analyst for a large
consulting firm
good for you and what kind of debt was
the 89
000 dollars it was all student loans oh
wow
yes sir what's your degree in yeah um so
it's a multi-faceted one it's industrial
engineering and accounting
and paul alisai oh wow from where
where'd you go
clemson okay good so you get out of
school how long you been on school
it's been about a year and a half now
okay oh you started attacking as soon as
you got out as hard as i could
yeah wow so what inspired you to do that
um
i think well i first i found out about
you guys through
the podcast and i've always had kind of
a proclivity for personal finance
and as i started learn more about it i
started to learn uh
just about how there was seemingly only
one model you know that everybody had to
follow this one path
it was unilateral and everybody did the
same thing as far as leveraging debt
to help them achieve their goals and um
listening to y'all's podcast it was
it was the first one that didn't try to
detach personal finance
from the rest of your life it was the
first time that that you know a
financial advisor
would talk to people about how there's
relational iq we talked to people about
how there's financial iq and talk to
people about their goals beyond just
be wealthy it's to also be generous
and when when i graduated i didn't
really know exactly what my student loan
debt was at i
kind of just kind of floated through
college financially and did what i could
to get by but
never really took things too serious and
then one night my dad and i sat down and
and summed it all up and that was kind
of the night that i just
you know i remember my world was
spinning around me i could look and see
my feet but i didn't see the ground it
was just
it was crazy um and then i thought back
to
to matthews 21 12 when when jesus he
cast out the money changers
in the temple and he cast out both the
sellers and the buyers
and he said anybody that participates in
that system they're thieves
and i wouldn't do that anymore and i saw
from that day on i was like this is it
you know i can't i can't be part of a
system that
is an oppressive debt system where so
many people struggle
and just to line the wallets of the
bigwigs you know in the city skyscrapers
so let me ask you this question stephen
doing the math you got a 20 000 gift so
that means she has about 69 000
in student loan debt but then your range
was 79.94
so this means man you were you were
you were living way and i mean way below
your means
yeah um talk to the listeners on why you
make it
that's what i was trying to figure out
like how did you do it and then one
why did you go to that extreme well um
so the the gift was an inheritance from
my uncle when he passed away
um his dream was always he had one rule
you know go to college just don't go to
law school
and so uh so that i don't want any
lawyers with family
well and so uh that was his thing was
he really wanted me to use that money to
succeed and so
um that was part of it you know i think
building a big why is a really really
important step in finding out
a lot about yourself and about your
personal motivations yeah um
you know i would you know clinch tight
to my why
throughout the whole process um and
another big thing ao actually you say it
all the time
and it's just become something i live by
but you when you say to speak what you
seek
until i see what i spoke um that's
that's been big for me yeah
and so part of my why is is
i actually want to go on to law school
and so
i want to keep going and i want to
succeed financially i want to be
generous
i want to leave a legacy and i hold on
to that and i tell myself
you know if i've done this i can even go
further and i keep talking about what my
goals are because
it's not a i wish for them it's one day
i'll get there
i just know it's hard work between me
and them and i don't want to get too
much into your personal business but
were you living at home during this time
or
yes i was oh yeah because i was just
trying to make sense with the math i'm
so happy
you say yes you were yeah my parents
they were very very generous i am
very blessed i love it i love it man so
now you're
making almost 100 000 a year and you
have no debt
in the world that's it and you're hauled
yeah i am 24.
are you single i'm not i've got a
girlfriend oh i was about to hook you up
right here in the ring
anthony's going to play matchmaker oh
she's right there she is beautiful yeah
i love it i'm sorry you're in what i
said
stay trouble of the love business right
there i'm just saying oh
man way to go way to go man thank you
okay so you were living at home and you
lived on nothing
still pretty genuinely i mean you truly
didn't go out to eat
and um i mean you were like the ultimate
cheap date oh it was awful
i mean well one thing for sure she
doesn't love you for your stuff
or for where you were taking her no it
was uh because
because there was none of that you were
just getting out of debt and you're free
now way to go man
thank you okay so you you just listened
in detail
and attacked it exactly like we teach
was there anything else you did special
well so um i i was you guys could
consider me like a ramsay super
user i was i was listening to every
single hour of every single podcast i
worked nights and weekends at a second
job
what was the second job i was delivering
pizzas oh good and um yeah
and i mean i was constantly listening to
the podcast consuming every bit of media
listening to debt-free degree listening
to about
the student loan crisis i mean
everything i could just to stay
laser focused and at no point did i
question
that i would be on this debt free stream
it was a question of when not if
come on man and it was that focus that
really really helped
yeah that's a big deal yeah you know uh
that's the difference when people
actually make it out of debt or they
don't
that is that they they just put blinders
on and it's that's their thing
for a short period of time 12 months in
your case not quite 12 months
one day short you know you had one
thing you're focused on and when you do
that you can do almost anything
but we live in an add culture where
we're all distracted by squirrel right i
mean everything right
everything comes along gets our
attention and pulls us off pulls our
eyes
off of the goal and the problem is not
how tough the goal is the problem is all
the stuff you have to give up
yes sir to stay on goal yeah with
anything
and this is no exception way to go i'm
so proud of you
who are your biggest cheerleaders so
i've got a list of people but but really
all my friends david and caitlin i want
to appreciate you guys for
always inviting me to things knowing
what my answer would be
um and candy mills leland miranda and
clarissa they
always cheering me on my mom my dad my
brother
for loving me and helping me to find my
why and of course my lovely girlfriend
for
for everything and then some tolerating
you being a cheap date
really there we go wait he wasn't a
cheap date yeah
she was yeah she was he was a focus date
that's what it was but that made him
cheap and there's nothing wrong with
that it was intentional cheapness
it was intentional cheapness yeah but
when the millennials he can do anything
he wants
exactly that's what i want to ask him
you're making six figures you debt-free
what's next
so i've got a couple short-term goals um
probably the one i'm most excited for is
i am cash flowing a trip to europe
touchdown i'm pumped about that i'll be
there in a year
and then um of course law school off in
the future i want to buy a house and
and get all that settled and your
uncle's not going to be happy
no he won't he won't but i think he'll
probably laugh at that uncle be happy
because he's going to pay for a cash
yeah uncle said no law school and then
he passed away so
anyway yeah all right way to go man we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's definitely the next step in your
uh in your process i'm so proud of you
very very well done
and we've got a copy of another copy of
the total money makeover for you to pay
it forward and
give away and so thank you man very very
well done steve it from
stephen from charlotte north carolina 89
000 paid off in 364 days making 79-94
busting it count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today we're taking your calls about your
life and your money open phones at
825-5225
jump on youtube or podcast land wherever
you listen to podcasts
and join anthony at the table
subscribe wherever you listen to podcast
or subscribe on his youtube channel the
table there's lots of people come to
the table and there are some wonderful
conversations there
that will cause your life to improve
and you will be substantially cooler
after having listened to the table
i cannot give you that promise with this
show but anthony can increase your cool
it's possible it is possible it can be
done christians with us in
california hi christian welcome to the
ramsey show
hello dave thanks for taking my call
sure
what's up um well i just want to say my
daughter
donnie she turned me into your the
reason i'm calling
is me and my wife we live in california
we are 50 i'm 53 and a half she's 52.
um really thinking on
stop maybe hopefully working from my
company in the next two years
55 56 we own two properties
one house i live on the other house we
rent
and i'm trying to get the best advice on
what to do um both homes have equity
the one i live on i my loan is
570. the house probably worth a million
for
the house i rent is worth about eight
seventy five i owe 143.
we were thinking of paying off the house
it's a 15-year loan i have six years
left
the idea was let's pay it off keep
renting it
get 35 3600 every month
use it for my primary home and
maybe move out of the state to rent the
two houses
and buy something somewhere else i love
the weather
i hate the politics in california
so i've been working 32 years for my
company
between me and my wife when you tell me
if i'm talking too much i'm giving you
too much info or you want you're fine
you're fine so what do you make a year
okay
my wife we make 190
and then the rental property
give us about 42 000 uh yeah so
where would you move well i'm thinking
right there man can you see
she's thinking what tennessee oh okay
all right
i don't know i'm thinking nevada you're
looking at
i i hear great stuff and when when would
you make this move
we i would like to stop working
from from a company in two three years
and we were thinking right now
i i have 120 000 dollars
on on my own stock account private
account that i i've gone with
and i'm thinking that's
possibly enough money especially if i
retire to have
cash on hand and the struggle is
do i want to have cash on hand and get a
new loan
on my rental which i have a three
percent loan 15 years
six years left to pay
[Music]
and get cash so if i want to leave the
state buy some property outside the
state
and still if i do that my rental
okay let's uh let's play a pretend a
minute okay
um you have a hundred and twenty
thousand and it's in
your company's stock right now right
no uh is it in your company's stock yes
or no
no no what's it in he's saying
uh i have uh some cash on the on the
e-trade account and then i have
facebook stock you have what
facebook facebook okay okay
yeah so let's play pretend that you sold
everything okay
i got a million two in my pocket if i
did my math right
yeah yeah that's your network
yeah millions maybe not counting not
counting your retirement accounts but
the
facebook stock and your two equities are
roughly a million too is that about
right
um well how are these hundreds i know
yeah you gave me the numbers that's
about right
okay so if you take a million to a
million two
and you come to tennessee missouri
kansas texas
nevada whatever you could buy a house to
live in and buy a rental house and pay
cash for it
yes well let's just do that
yeah you know my wife loves the ocean
well i didn't you said you told me you
were moving i didn't tell you you were
moving
yeah no i'm moving okay the only
question now is she's coming with you
it's ugly she i think she is yeah okay
so i mean maybe maybe you're going to
florida i don't know where you're going
i'm joking i'm joking around with you
here but here's the thing if i don't
like the
politics in an area that means that
those politics are going to affect
economics they already have and they're
going to again
including the real estate that you leave
back there when you try to leave there
and leave keep this rental property and
have a long distance rental property no
go put a rental property in an area
where you believe in the area
and is near where you live and you're
going to do better on the rental
property
at that point and you know you've
completely cleaned up everything because
i would
not have 120 000 in any single stock
right anthony right right
right right that and that's the key
thing for me too david i like how you're
talking about how you just broke that
down 1.2 he can he can move to nevada
buy a home for a half a million buy
another rental property for maybe two or
three hundred thousand dollars and still
have some money left over to invest in
mutual funds you have a diversified
portfolio
exactly and you know have your income to
offer the rental you have no house
payment
um no taxes no income taxes anyway
and uh if you pick your state wisely and
um
uh you know and and you can do some
investing but i
i don't buy single stocks well
particularly
high volatile tech stocks
like facebook yeah um and i don't have
long distance
landlording and i don't have debt
and so i'm trying to give you the gift
of all of three of those things with
this proposal
yeah no long-distance landlording no
debt and no high-risk stock investments
when we're done and then you can settle
in and enjoy the next
portion of your life because i doubt
you're going to do nothing you're too
young
yeah you're probably going to go do
something you can only play so much golf
or fish
and he said anyway you need to do
something and create some income just
for the fun of it not because you
have to but the natural progression
doesn't have to be you put your feet up
and quit
at 50 something years old yeah so now
he's definitely not going to florida
he's not going to to that ocean either
you don't think so no state tax right
no they don't have it they don't have
anything i'm going to florida
well there you go when will you be back
[Laughter]
because i was kind of expecting you to
be on the show next week so
hey dave we're we're in a new age we're
scheduled we're scheduled here i could
do the show from
the beach house in florida yeah that's
assuming we let you
[Laughter]
see you're making all kinds of
assumptions now no they don't have an
income tax it's one of the reasons that
people
uh tend to go there's a ton that half
the time in florida when you're walking
around you're talking to new yorkers you
know i'm just messing with you i'm from
florida i'm not from but you know i
can't i was living in florida before i
came here you were in jacksonville when
you came here
it was beautiful yeah and as far as i
know you don't have an outstanding
income tax bill from when you were there
before dude
absolutely okay good i'm glad to hear
that absolutely
so that's what i would do christian is i
would just have a clean
break a one fell swoop you'll have no
income tax at all on the sale of your
personal residence up to
500 000 in gain married filing jointly
250 000 for a single and i think you're
married still
and the uh the rental you will have
capital gains
on it or you could do a 1031 tax
deferred exchange and
sell that into a 1031 escrow
and buy your rental out of that when you
get to
whatever city or state you're going into
and have zero taxes you'll roll the
taxes the capital gains over
so that's another move you can make
there facebook whatever you make on that
you're going to pay some taxes on but
dude you need to get out of that by
friday anyway
absolutely not particularly into
facebook just predicting
volatility in that world this
is the ramsey chef
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we talk to you
about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
laurel is with us or laurel is with us
in
houston texas to start off this hour hi
laurel how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so me and my husband are 31 years old
and we're in baby step 7
and we just had our first baby wow
congrats
yes thanks so i was planning on going
back to work
after my three-month maternity leave but
now i'm thinking i might want to be a
stay-at-home mom
and i'm kind of nervous about the
decision because
i make over half our household income
and
more importantly i'm worried about
getting back into a career
career after maybe staying at home for
seven to ten years with
all our kids until they go into school
so i just wanted to get your thoughts on
is this an okay financial decision
and also do you have any advice on
getting back into a career after
being out maybe up to 10 years your home
is paid for
yes and you guys make how much each
i make a hundred and forty thousand
dollars and my husband makes a hundred
thousand dollars before taxes
what do you do i'm a chemical engineer
[Music]
okay well i i don't know
a lot uh about the tactical aspects of
what it takes to be a chemical engineer
on a day in and day out basis
i do grasp the idea that it is chemistry
and a lot of math
and neither of those are going to change
right chemistry is not going to evolve
to where you don't even know where you
don't understand the formulas in seven
years
and certainly math and certainly math is
not going to uh there may be some
discoveries
and some things that there will be some
discoveries and things that
um you know will affect things you may
keep up with those just by reading and
staying on top of things
but i don't know that you know for
instance if you were a
uh a software engineer
seven years from now you would be an
absolute idiot you would have no idea
yeah what's going on
because it will have completely changed
in seven years agreed
agreed but i think your the world that
you're in is much more stable because
it's based on
uh formulas and suppositions is it not
that's true so um it's not a
rapidly evolving completely turning over
set of information
that you would become irrelevant in
seven years and you would in some
industries i mean there's a lot of
things that are moving very very fast
and
in seven years i mean i look back seven
years in broadcasting how much it's
changed you know but uh but you could
you can come back in with that skill set
now you know you may have a
a process to do that but you're a
hundred percent debt free he makes a
hundred thousand dollars a year you guys
can live on that can't you
yeah so we're confident of that but i
would definitely want to
go back to work at some point so i guess
it
just makes us nervous to have such a big
change but we
could easily obviously have a good life
on a hundred thousand dollars
and i don't know why you couldn't take
on a a a lightweight consulting gig ever
so often to keep your toe in the water
that's what i was going to say
especially
like the last two years like mainly with
the not with a money goal but a goal of
staying relevant
right okay
and i was and and i'm not a father so i
mean listen to dave more you listen to
me but i'm also thinking like maybe you
spend the first five years
and then the last two years you start
just inching your way back into
picking up some consulting stuff going
out around it so this way when you're
ready to go full throttle in it you're
already immersed back into
any changes that have already been there
but i would say the first you know few
years yeah focus on your kids
you guys have worked so hard to get to
this point
to be able to make these choices yeah
and you're in a position to make the
choices
and here's the thing you will not get
to 84 years old and look back and go oh
darn i didn't maximize my career
yeah you will get to 84 and say oh darn
i miss those kids i missed their
childhood i could have stayed home
yeah that's what i'm most scared of yeah
so quit
yeah okay all right thank you that
helped me feel a lot better yeah that's
what we would do at the ramsey house
anyway
because money's only good for one thing
causing the things in your life that you
want to have happen
that's what it's for and that includes
generosity
yeah and the only reason we invest is so
we can cause more things to happen in
our life we're controlling more
variables
in our life and you've done that with
baby step seven way to go
you know what dave i like how you just
said that man
it even got me kind of emotional because
when i heard that i heard her say man
i wish my parents would have been around
maybe a little bit more i'm grateful
that they did what they had to do
they had to walk yeah and work um but
hearing that
she has the opportunity to be more
involved into the younger people's life
that is to me that is more valuable than
making a whole lot of money because
that's a strong investment
given that that's their situation that's
what she's able to number one number two
it's her desire yes where you know we've
got
that's not to put shame on a lady who
chooses to say i want to work
no i know i get i get joy out of being
at home with the kids
when i'm at home but i also like good
joy out of my career yeah
and um and but she just had a baby and
she's like no i'm done
tap out tap out yeah and so that that's
cool so
yeah we don't we don't shame stayed on
moms and we don't shame uh not
stay-at-home moms absolutely my moms are
not that
uh but i do for me and my future i i
want to give
the chance the opportunity yes yes yeah
it's not a matter of
if they need to work exactly it's do
they want to and it's like hey it's like
if you want to quit whenever you want to
quit quit
you know do your thing i think we for me
i really i really love what we teach
because i believe when you're debt free
and you're making good amount of money
it brings
options and you can choose to live the
life that you want to live
not the life that you have to live and
sometimes just getting rid of the debt
does that come you don't even have to be
all the way
into you know paid for house and
everything but i mean the number of
times i've taken a call here
and um you know we have a minivan
yeah that the payment is 700 on and i
could quit work if it wasn't for the
minivan
got rid of the minivan just now it's
gone
say bye bye odyssey goodbye
see you baby out of here
i mean really i mean but we make choices
and we like feel like we're trapped then
by the debt and you can just
amputate the minivan and get your life
back
yeah amputate the tahoe baby yeah get
your life back
and uh we trade out
chunks of who we are in order to pay
payments
on stuff that really doesn't change our
life
absolutely yeah so way to go good
choices
good thought pattern i love it good
critical thinking
this is good this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
our famous ten dollar 825-5225 is almost
over learn how to make faster and real
progress with your money when you check
out this
ten dollar sale you can save up to sixty
percent
on over 40 best selling books
like the newly repackaged graduate
survival guide it's beautiful
ready to uh help the graduates out and
there's graduates everywhere this
weekend there was everywhere around here
man it was oh yeah like the high school
is all busted loose around here
big time and uh anyway shop for a ten
dollar sale
online at ramseysolutions.com total
money makeovers ten dollars coleman's
book
rachel's books christy's books deloney's
books all ten dollars everybody's books
are ten dollars it's pretty cool
plus uh we got a gift for you you can
enter to win our ramsey cash
giveaway but hurry the giveaway ends may
31st here
any second we're giving away 500 cash
every week and a grand prize of five
thousand dollars cash of course no
purchase
necessary you can enter daily must be 18
or older to win
text cash to 33789
ramsey solutions.com check out the store
open phones here triple eight eight two
five five two two five daniel is in
nashville hi daniel how are you hi dave
hi anthony thanks for taking my call
yeah what's up um so my wife got
my wife and i got married about a year
and a half ago we graduated about two
years ago
um and we set a goal for about five
years we want to
move outside of the united states to
just share the love of christ with a
place that doesn't know it yet
and so right now we're living in
nashville we're both teachers here and
we were going to move
closer to home to new mexico and so our
plan was to buy a house for about five
years and then to sell it and then leave
but just with the way the market has
kind of exploded over the last
six months 12 months 18 months um we
are just not quite sure what to do i've
run some numbers in an excel spreadsheet
so i have my own idea but i was i was
curious about what you would do if
you're in my shoes
what are y'all going to do in nashville
i mean they're leaving nashville i mean
mexico to new mexico are y'all going to
be missionary work or are you going to
still teach
and we plan on continuing to teach
okay for five years still okay so we're
building up a war chest to do the
mission field after five years
is that right yeah just growing in
maturity
okay in our marriage and professionalism
all that stuff
good for you okay good well obviously if
the housing market continues like it is
for five years which it won't
um you would be more than okay buying a
house right
definitely because you'd make a brazil
you'd make a bazillion dollars but
i'm not assuming that's going to happen
and i'm guessing you aren't either
that's right so what is your fear of
buying a house and holding it five years
um i'm just not sure what the timelines
are for like when it's better to rent
versus when it's
better to buy some something say two
years something say
you know you should have at least seven
years on the higher end but um
i think after running the numbers i
think five years is safe but what i
don't want to happen is like
the the same sort of bubble that
happened like 12 years ago 10 years ago
or so
um and then you know we because people
are overpaying about
you know 15 or 20 000 asking price um
and so yeah i don't want to overpay by
you know 20 000 and then
the uh the house is not worth
as much and we end up paying more um
trying to just like resell the house
than
we would have if we had rented for five
years okay
none of us know what the market is going
to do exactly
and um but i i do not do
anything financially predicated on
the crash and the end of the world
okay if i'm going to do that then we
just need to
buy bullets and water
and a tent right so i don't i don't but
could real estate uh offset if you go
back and actually look at the numbers
and
and the bubble of 2008 was a real estate
bubble that burst
right it was the first one some of the
other than the great depression it's the
only time we've had a we've had some
economic downturns but we've never had a
real estate downturn like 2008 was but
here's the interesting thing
in almost every market within five years
it had fully recovered
okay i mean look at the history of it
you can look at the that's a database
thing that's not a feeling
and so you know i remember saying well
you know the
people saying well you know scottsdale
arizona phoenix arizona oh my god
you know it was artificially high it
dove vegas took a big drop
it was the fastest growing city in
america and it dropped
way down most areas dropped down it was
the first time we'd seen
homes single-family homes actually go
down in value in some of these markets
they were all back in three years
okay they were and that was a dramatic
one
now so now the question then is how much
money are you going to make or are you
in a stagnant market so here's two
here's a couple of numbers if you want
to nerd out further on it just for the
fun of it
get with the real estate agent out there
and
number one you got to be debt free right
anthony yep you got to have the
emergency fund
got every down payment before we even
talk about this but assuming you've done
that
you put it on a 15-year fixed rate where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay these are the
guidelines we use around here
so you don't buy too much house and you
don't buy a house when you're broke but
once you're doing all that then you can
look at two statistics with
your real estate agent out there and uh
i would say
pre-2020 i wouldn't use 2020 numbers or
2021 numbers because they're
they are unusually high in terms of how
fast properties have gone up in value
there's very few times in history you
can look back and see this much
escalation in value
or cost on property uh this fast
so i would say you know like 18 17 18 19
in this market pull up on the mls for me
ask the real estate agent
what the average appreciation rate was
in the neighborhood that you're
considering
okay okay and then that will tell you if
you're going to make enough
during your holding period to offset
your costs
okay so you would just take that rate
and then that would be the rate i would
use
because that's probably more average
than what we're experiencing right now
that's you know what we're experiencing
right now i don't think is going to
continue for five years that's
unrealistic
i could be wrong but i don't i don't
think so the second thing you can ask
them for and this might be the most
important number in this whole
conversation is ask them for average dom
prior to 2020 average days on the market
how hot a market is this and if the
average dom
on a house the price range you're
looking at is 270 days that's nine
months
don't buy you're gonna get stuck
but if the average dom is nine days
prior to 2020
then that market was hot before the
pandemic
i see and you know you got markets that
were that way already they were already
running
20 day 30 day 40 40-day doms
and if you've got average days on the
market then that market's going to move
you'll be able to get out of the house
i'm not as concerned about how much
you're going to make on it i'm fairly
comfortable you're going to make some
money
but i am concerned you can't sell it
when you get ready to leave and you end
up with a rental property in the states
and you're on the mission field
oh shoot me get it over with i hate that
idea
sounds good does that make sense to you
yeah yeah hey man good question and
thank you for your
willingness to serve the lord in that
way very very cool
this real estate market's got everybody
talking you know it does dave
i mean it's because i mean you can move
in a place in 20 seconds make money on
it right now oh yeah
trust me i know i'm tempted i'm tempted
right now
you just bought that i'm and i'm tempted
how long have you owned that property
seven months seven months and you
already make some money on it oh my
goodness
i have offers on the house right now
dave let's see there you go
yeah that's how it works when you're
anthony o'neil i'm tempted he's just a
money-making machine
listen look at him listen man he looks
like money doesn't it no i don't know
about all that
i look good but i don't know like money
[Laughter]
but you know what told me that's i mean
i'm just you know but i'm not going to
sell i'm not going to sell
yeah until next friday when he comes
back in here and tells me he's sold
already now
someone comes to me and says i give you
they already they already are
now but i'm talking about they give me a
lot more money well
that's a lot i need give me six figures
over asking price
whoa
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why are you looking at me like that
kelly uh i'm kelly kelly gave it
she just gave him the aunt kelly look
that was aunt kelly looking in there i
saw that eye roll
i sure did i saw it it was real hey
listen
it's a wild market wild market this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the debt-free stage right here in the
lobby of ramsey solutions
philip and leah are with us hey guys how
are you hey dave welcome where do you
guys live
dayton ohio oh love it very cool well
welcome to nashville
thank you and all the way down here to
do a debt-free scream how much did you
pay off
84 000 all right and how long did this
take
three years and 10 months got it love it
and your range of income during that
time
we started at 80 and then took a dip
down to next to nothing
and then now we ended at 165.
wow and they went a double okay
so uh what do you guys do for a living
now so i am a sales operations and
incentive leader with a
large electrification company and
i am the director of city lights which
is an outreach organization for our
church and i manage a team of
teaching pastors and i'm a lay counselor
and
teaching on the teaching team at our
church oh wow cool which church
south brook christian church yeah okay
very cool
good well welcome you guys very good
what kind of debt was this 84
000. uh we had it all we had the student
loans we had the car
the credit cards the medical the taxes
man everything you're just like normal
normal normal normal people
but then something happened we
knew that we wanted to get out of debt
we didn't know how to we didn't know a
path other than just do the normal
make your monthly payments it wasn't a
clear line of sight of how to do it
quicker
we saw a conference of yours in
september of 2016 in dayton
and we were like we want to do that that
makes sense that was a great night hall
that is a great theater in there i
remember this
yeah and it is uh it's fabulous i think
we got
uh really great seats because my parents
work for wfcj 93.7
radio station is the only radio station
in ohio that does your entire show live
yeah not simulcast so i think that was
probably the hookup that they
you know said you guys need to be in the
front row you got connections i like it
okay so you get on the front row and you
get the fire
hose go up to a water fountain to get a
drink and we turned on a fire hose wow
it blew my mind how much it made sense
just simple
things to do so then that following
february of 2017 we did the home study
with another couple
and we were like okay we can do this and
i'm the numbers guy
i just laid it out at the current income
level if we have our budget set this way
three years we're done and that was all
fine and danny the first year we
actually were ish
only about 13 000 out of the 84.
and then i got laid off a year into our
debt-free journey i was laid off for the
first time in my career and you went to
zero income
zero and it was protect our four walls
and let's get to the next position let's
grow our family and
what's up next for us and
luckily thankfully the lord provided and
i was able to find my next position
even get promoted slightly higher level
and we were back on board
um and leah steps into her role and then
yeah so then leah got a found a role
that's more
up her alley and literally march of
march 15th of 2020 right as was my start
date oh that's great
yeah so yeah i went to work everybody
else went home
and and then that just created our
snowball so
that 2020 was an interesting time
because there were so many we were
meeting so many needs we were feeding
so many people and i was seeing so much
you know devastation from shut down
and yet i was making money
and then getting a promotion and a raise
during that time
and then he gets a promotion and a raise
and it was like
it felt uncomfortable but it felt
providential we because i kind of felt
like we we paid our dues we have also
been
both not working yeah living off of a
severance
yeah well i mean you know and the best
way to have sympathy with broke people
is not be one of them
right right yeah i'm curious throughout
you all's journey
i know you lost your job would you say
that was the hardest part of this
journey
or was that one of them what would you
say was the hardest thing to do
throughout this journey
persevere persevere i think it's those
darn envelopes i don't ever carry them
with me at the right time
they're always in the buffet and i and
i'm out shopping and i need the envelope
that was always our gripe i'm like would
you please take the envelopes when you
go somewhere i'm not going to shop
anywhere
yeah you'll end up somewhere oh okay
yeah perseverance perseverance was the
hardest thing just because it was
it's it takes time yeah and it doesn't
just happen overnight
yeah yeah you know we had uh our entree
leadership summit in dallas last week
and i was with business owners and
business leaders
uh almost 3 000 of them and an amazing
number of them had the best year
ever in 2020 and there's almost like a
survivor's guilt
like you know other people are hurting
but i'm having the best year ever
yeah but you did you know you did
completely overcome
change adapt pivot whatever you want to
call
unprecedented whatever the number
whatever the words where we were all
using to try to survive
um and ramsay ended up having a better
year than we had originally predicted
uh but the amount of work we put in and
the
stuff we did to cause that to happen i
don't feel any survivor's guilt at all i
don't feel
guilt at all we earned every penny of it
and we helped a ton of people in a time
when they were hurting so
it was exactly what it should be but
there's a thing out there that a lot of
it's there's an amazing number of people
in america that it was their best year
of their life income wise right
that was us and they and and they're
looking around and going yeah but i
really can't tell anybody because all
these other people are you know it kind
of feels weird
yeah but we wouldn't have had that best
year ever if it hadn't been for some of
the planning
and some of the things that we had put
into place a couple years ago and the
route we need
and stay on budget and spend the cash
only yeah and
uh yeah to kind of go is that what you
attribute this to what would you say the
reason to get out of that is
well the best ways what's the technique
what's the thing you got to do
it it is just keeping the main thing the
main thing and understanding but
i would say we also helped some other
people once we got
on board and saw what we could do and
because he's so brilliant with math and
the spreadsheets
we there's another couple that we walked
alongside and they were like oh we'll
never be able to be out of debt it'll be
10 years
phillip said let me run the math and it
was more like five and then it seemed
doable to them
so then we'd find somebody else and we'd
say hey why don't you come over for
dinner on friday
let's go over your finances and let's do
it together and
just tell us your life story and we'll
help you just just let's go through your
underwear
it was because we could see like
sometimes we'd be like okay well we
don't want to
make that mistake again we don't want to
do that yeah let's just we did dumb too
it's okay
and so empathy was you know was built
through that process so that kept us
motivated just keep going keep going
because we really could see the end in
sight very cool
yeah real quick before we let you do
your debt free scream
you're kids you have kids what do you
think what is one thing they're going to
learn from this journey bring them in
what are their eight names and ages yeah
we have three children
our 18 year old is flowing the nest and
she's working really hard in columbia
south carolina doing her thing working
good for her
yeah and then this is presley she is our
12 year old
and then this is aven and she is eight
almost nine so
i would say they all had different
experiences our 18 year old got told no
a lot there was a lot of things
unfortunately for alex that was like
you know we started this journey i think
she thought we were crazy she was a part
of
building those i think we had a picture
but it was like the the thermometers and
the color
she understood all that and her
perspective is probably a little bit
different and then even she said this
morning we were laying by the pool
at the hotel and she said man in 10
years because i said something about us
being millionaires in 10 years and she
said
in 10 years i'll be 18. it made sense to
her like what that looks
like and she said how old are you guys
be he's like we're not telling but
anyway
i think what they're going to do yeah
what they're going to learn is um
you know i remember a shopping trip with
you presley and we had the envelope and
i said
this is what we got and you want to
spend it all that's fine but if you want
to put something back
what isn't really important then just
decide she made a really good decision
and i think just those little things
along the way of just being disciplined
that we have the money to spend but do
we want to spend it
that's it we're not in congress we have
to have a limit right
i love it way to go you guys we're so
proud of y'all we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's your next
step
thank you is moving on to wealth and
just outrageous generosity continued
you've obviously got big hearts
for ministry and for everything else way
to go very very well done
and another copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and pay it
forward with one of those dinners where
you go through your friends finances
that's right we will do it philip and
leah presley and haven from dayton ohio
84 000
paid off in three years and 10 months
making 80 to nothing to 165.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one
[Applause]
this is how it's done boom
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
paying off debt is smart saving and
investing is smart being generous is
smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that's often forgotten and that's
protecting your family from emergencies
there's offense and there's defense
there's ten kinds of insurance coverage
you really might need
depending on your life stage and we've
built a tool to show you what coverage
you need to add drop or adjust and it
only takes five minutes
we are not in the life insurance
business we're not in the insurance
business at all
but we will teach you and rank your
to-do list
by importance and email it to you so you
can get your plan
in place fast it's called the coverage
checkup it's completely free
and it could be the most important five
minutes you spend today
donald wrote in and said i feel and i
kind of like how he put it he said for
anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it right now you never know
when something will happen
you never want to leave your family in a
bad situation amen
so get your phone out text check up to
33789 or you can visit daveramsey.com
checkup don't let an emergency sneak up
on you you got to play offense and
defense
if you want to win with money
lisa is with us in washington hi lisa
welcome to the ramsey
hi there hi dave hi anthony hey what's
up my call
sure well we sort of have probably maybe
a boring question but we
my husband and i have spent the last 30
years getting ready for retirement we're
retired
and we realize we've been foolish we
have not had a will this entire time
and so putting together we want to put
together a will and
we were asked are we going to do a joint
or a mirrored wills
and i don't know the difference i can't
really find a good answer so i thought
call dave i have never uh
known anyone to advise a joint will
because you need to have
separate wills because you're separate
people and the chances of you dying at
the same time
a joint well is just like the two
attached at the hip is all it is
i would do a mirrored i i that's what
sharon and i have done we have a
mirrored will
and a mirrored will is if we both die
at the same exact moment or within
seconds of each other or something plain
wreck or something like that
everything's the same when we're both
gone
that's a mirror okay and so the only
thing that's different is
what happens if i die before her what is
how is it handled with her
and if she dies before me how's it
handled and by the way that's exactly
the same we just changed the names out
in other words she gets everything if i
die i get everything if she dies
and we both die it works the same either
way
after we're both gone does that make
sense so that the reason
anybody brings up a mirrored will
they're identical except you just change
the names in and out
is it's a lot less expensive because it
it they don't charge you two
full will prices okay
emotionally they shouldn't they
shouldn't
okay i think that i'm like have that con
i have a little bit of control freak on
me after i'm gone
we work so hard no we did not inherit
our wealth
we built it we worked hard we sacrificed
and i think i just thought of problems i
didn't know anything about this and then
until i
asked somebody asked me the question
well that doesn't neither one of these
address
the control freak issue okay
the only difference is see they're two
separate documents
or or those two same some a similar
version of those two separate documents
attached at the hip
joint versus alike except mirrored
that's the only difference in your
question now then as far as control
freaking then that's a matter of setting
up a trust
leaving the money into trust and the
terms of the trust help you be a control
freak from the grave
okay and i've done some i've done some
of that now i believe in that to a
degree i mean i don't want to be
overboard with it but
um i really you know if i got if i got a
29 year old doing heroin i do not want
to finance that
right exactly and i'm thinking if if
there is you know dementia or
alzheimer's on either one of our parts
the other dies we have a will set that
we know
this is what we want and then you know
i'm just trying to control
something like that where it's changed
after let's say
my husband dies and i have um
you know dementia the will would be
invalid you would not be of sound
mind if you change it with dementia
you ever heard like the movie say i dave
ramsey being of sound mind
yes yes that's what that means okay
that's
that's the missing piece that's why we
called you for your brilliance so
thank you it's okay it's all good yeah
you cannot execute a contract of any
kind
including a last will and testament if
you're not of sound mind and if you do
it can be undone
yeah yeah dave in your expertise i've
never heard of it
so i'm asking to learn too have you ever
heard of someone where a joint will
is not a good idea no yeah i'm not
i'm not an estate planning expert but
i've never i mean i've because it
complicates
yeah it over complicates it if you'll
treat it as two individual people
yeah that have the same wishes yeah okay
i mean we're not trying to act like
we're not married or we don't care it's
not trying to separate the marriage or
something like that it's not like a
prenup it's not that kind of thing
but you're just it's a lot cleaner and
it helps you through
think through okay if you go first
here's what we do if i go first here's
what we do
and you have to kind of think through
that because it might be different if
you had step children
right or uh you know like if she had
children i didn't have children and we
married second marriage or something
you know you kind of think through you
got to really think through how things
are going to play out then
yeah and so forth so the sound mind
thing is wild
yeah i actually got the weirdest deal
when i was in my 20s i was buying real
estate
and i bought a mortgage note
on a house okay i bought the bank sold
it to me
the money was owed to this little ripoff
finance company
yeah okay and i bought the note from
them it was it was like a twelve
thousand dollar note
and it was uh i bought it they couldn't
it hadn't been paid on in four years and
so i bought it for 500 bucks
so now the guy owes me twelve thousand
dollars and i paid five hundred dollars
you're following me right
right it's a second mortgage on this
house so i go to collect it
and it's up in the country and the son
of the guy turns out the guy had died
and the son of the guy gets mad and
threatens to whip me
and so i said well dude you know you can
threaten with me if you want but i'll
just foreclose on the note so we got to
figure this out
and he still it was not it was not
pretty so i just got out of there while
i
my my scalp was intact and uh
started foreclosure oh wow and they sued
me
to stop the foreclosure on a
technicality the suit got thrown out but
while we went to court it was just a
little it was it like going to traffic
court it wasn't it wasn't a big time
but it was just very interesting because
i got in there and they brought
doctors and nurses and everything and it
turns out that the old man had financed
windows
with this rip-off window company and he
had alzheimer's
and didn't even know what he was doing
and so the note was actually invalid
wow but because of a technicality
i beat it and was able to continue the
foreclosure but i couldn't do it
because i just knew it was wrong yeah
yeah and so i walked up to him
afterwards
now he ain't gonna whip my butt because
i'm in the court right i'm sitting in
front of the judge and i'm like dude i
had no idea all you had to do was say
dad was ill
right i said i got 500 bucks in this and
i paid that lawyer over there 600 so i
got 1100
in this if you'll give me the 500 i'll
eat the lawyer fee
just to own this story because this
story is awesome and so uh because
your daddy shouldn't have gotten ripped
off and i'm not i don't participate in
that yeah
did you get the 500. yeah he gave me 500
bucks and i walked out and he he had no
problem after that because otherwise
he's going to lose the house right to
somebody yeah
i wasn't going to take it but it just
was wrong but see that's that's a person
of not of sound mind
entered into a contract to buy
replacement windows on his house he
probably didn't even need
for 12 000 puts a lien on his house
dies and now i show up in this story
what six uh probably three years later
four years later
after that but that contract was not
enforceable
because if that if if that little
technicality in the court case which
they you can't bring a court case within
so many days of a foreclosure
or they can't be heard so they didn't
even have the court case but if that
doctor
and nurses had gotten on the stand and
said i'm here to testify that man had
alzheimer's at the time this contract
was
signed that contract would have been
thrown out i would have gotten
zero and because i bought an invalid
contract i didn't know it wow i mean i
didn't know it was all fraud
wow but it was scummy people i mean i
knew the finance company i bought it
from was coming but i had no idea the
whole deal was wow was was bass ackwards
like that
very interesting though i learned a lot
yeah yeah learned where not to go
and ask somebody something because you
get your butt whip number one
number two i learned when you get in
front of the judge that you can win on a
technicality and still be wrong
uh you know number three i learned that
when you do the right thing you get a
great story
absolutely absolutely
did not take the family's little house
they can have it oh my goodness gracious
wow wow that puts this hour of the
ramsey show
in the box
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting
from the dollar car rental studios it's
the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones here at 825-5225
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
samantha starts off this hour in dallas
texas hi samantha how are you
i'm good thank y'all so much for taking
my call sure um
okay a quick summary um so my husband
and i are paid off except for our house
um our debt free um and we're currently
saving
a lot of money because for our next
house we want to buy land
and build a house on it cool but i also
went to move some old 401
k accounts into an ira and
they told me it would be about twenty
thousand dollars to convert it to a raw
and so i'm wondering is it better to put
more money towards the land and next
house or is it better to
pay the tax bill now and go ahead and
convert that into a roth account
we'll have the cash either way
neither one is under the dumb column
i mean you're going to have tax-free
growth on that roth from this point
forward that would be awesomeness
and of course paying cash are almost
paying cash for the land
and the property going forward is be
awesome as well
either one is fine either one moves you
ahead in your wealth building
um let me think which one i would do
what what what would you do i'm doing
the land you're doing the land
yeah mr real estate over here oh yeah
i'm going down to the land
hmm i don't like the irs that much they
come second
well i don't like them i'm trying to
keep them away from it later that's the
point so that's true
what's your household income um our
household income right now
is probably around 170. i eventually
want to be a stay-at-home mom though so
we're living off my husband's
yeah right now you're making bank okay
so how much do you need for this land
the land we're looking around um 150
how much 60 i'm sorry 60. we already
have 60.
okay so you're 90 away see i think
you're gonna do
both but you don't have to do the but
the only question is the order do we do
the roth now and then the land
and pay cash uh do both or do we do the
land and then
convert to a roth by then the account
will have grown a little more and it
will be more than 20.
but i still would convert it later i'm
probably with anthony i'm probably going
to go ahead and save up and pay cash for
the land
but then i'm also going to conv you can
convert this to a roth anytime you want
right you don't have to do it on this
current transaction right
so go ahead and move it to a traditional
do your land deal
but come back and flip it to a roth
later when you're debt-free
okay perfect pay your cash pay your
taxes at that time of course
when you do that that that that i would
do i like it that's good i like that
now how long do you think that would be
dave it didn't sound like it's gonna be
two years
yeah so then 20 000 is maybe what 22
maybe
yeah but you know may it might be you
know i don't know it depends on what the
account goes to but
here's the principle too that we can go
back to okay we tell people not to
let's say she was in baby step two right
we would never do that right
we always you know need to get out of
that first right and i wouldn't do it in
place of baby step six
i would say finish getting your house
paid off before you convert to a roth
yes
and create extra tax money yes while
you're doing that
and so this is kind of like that i see
you now yes and so that's that that
got me over to your side on doing the
land first i think your your instincts
were
right on that thank you for admitting
that dave thanks a lot very good and i'm
i'm dave ramsey you're anthony o'neil
now okay
we can switch my stock just went up
considerably
i'm way cooler than i was five minutes
ago you're cooler i'm richer yes
wait a minute that wasn't a good trade
right pam pam's in akron ohio hey pam
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and anthony thanks for taking
my call sure
my husband and i are on baby step six
and he is 57 and currently eligible for
retirement
he has a pension and if he takes that
pension as a lump
sum it would be about 387 000.
currently he has about 135
000 in his 401k and our question
is should he retire and receive the lump
sum
and should we dip into our 401k to
finish
paying off our mortgage or should he
keep working
until the mortgage is paid and then
consider retirement
what's his yearly income right now
right now he makes about 45 and
i make about 55. what do you owe on the
house
77 000. oh man
well you understand he can't access
either one of these until he's 59 and a
half without penalties right
yeah we were thinking under the rule of
55
he could access the 401k money yeah you
can probably get some more he'd probably
get
some rmd out of there but i don't think
you can get it all
um okay i don't know he might um
hmm well number one if you're going to
retire yes you take the lump sum always
and yes you roll it to an ira
and you don't pay taxes on it when you
do that okay that's number one move
um our concern i guess too about
retiring um in the lump sum is this like
he's eligible right now
and if something happens to him like say
before
you know now and two years from now when
the house is paid or whatever he keeps
working
then if he passes away or something
happens then we lose that pension money
we would only get about a year's worth
of salary as a benefit
instead of the whole pension
is he ill no he's in good health
okay he just drives too fast okay
we hear him in the background like he is
right
all right i just wondering why you
didn't think he's going to make it okay
you just never know i guess yeah the
other thing is this
okay um
i'm gonna read into this that this is
not his dream
job okay you're correct yeah okay
okay factory job he's only
57 years old
i'm 60 okay and i'm gonna work 20 more
years just because i love what i do
i'm gonna work till they won't let me
talk anymore because i don't make sense
so um that might be tomorrow but i'm
hoping for 20 more years anyway
but the uh uh so the point is is that he
doesn't have to stop
creating an income
just because he retires and so we
thought about that
yeah what i would do is if you can pull
the money without
paying any penalties on it under
55 rule if you've already looked into
that and you can confirm that
with a financial advisor with a tax
person without me doing it on the radio
because that's not good
a good plan then yeah i i'm gonna quit
either way i'm gonna roll it to an ira
either way
and if i can pull enough out without
paying any penalties to pay off the
house i'm gonna pay it off now i'm gonna
pay it off later otherwise
and i'm gonna take a bow
and then they give you a standing
ovation and then you get what's called
an
encore career
and for the next 20 years do something
you love with your life and make
twice as much as 45 while having fun
doesn't mean you have to make nothing
for the rest of your life i love it
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you're tired
of feeling stuck
with your money like you'll never get
out of debt or you'll never have enough
save for the future
it does not have to be this way you can
make progress with your money and you
can make it faster than you think
the only way to make it happen is with a
budget and that's why you need a ramsey
plus
membership you get access to the premium
version of the world's best budgeting
app
every dollar and you'll plan out every
dollar
that you're going to spend and save
before the month begins it connects to
your bank
so you never miss a transaction you get
customized budget reports
to show you exactly where you can find
more money you can get into financial
peace university and go through the
whole class
plus a bunch of other classes and all
kinds of groups
that you can participate in and even
online
coaching as well when you budget and you
get intentional with your money
you will make progress fast and you can
start a ramsey plus membership today
for free if you want to start the free
trial of ramsey plus
text trial 233 789
text trial 233-789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings you get free
samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
so dave today's question comes from sean
in missouri sean says i'm 21 years old
and currently making 31 000
per year at my job i've been able to
complete some college courses in the
evenings
but it's challenging to keep up with
school while working full-time
i have a plan that will allow me to work
part-time during school and graduate
without loans
is moving is moving to a part-time job
worth the risk or should i keep
my full-time job and continue with
college courses
part-time uh great question sean and
and one of the key things that i
personally teach our young people is to
work
part-time while you're in college and
part-time meaning anywhere between
uh 20 and max 22 hours maybe
and so yes i don't have a problem with
you going down a part-time so you can
focus on getting your education because
i want you to do that i do not want you
to go down to
working less than part-time the only
time i am
okay with full-time work is if you're
full-time
it's not intervening with your education
and or your full-time going part-time in
school
but in this situation when you're going
full-time uh part-time hours are
good especially if you can do that and
still graduate 100
debt-free yeah i mean 12 hours a day
that's not
bad yeah that's part-time it's half a
day right yeah i mean 12 to 12 half days
12 hours a day
yeah well wait no i thought you mean
like 12 hours a week
you know come on dave davey's he's
trying to confuse me y'all
that's half time i mean let's work in
half no you're not even working full
time it's just half i mean now you're
talking about working 12 hours maybe on
saturday and yet he doesn't have to work
monday through friday okay
you know come on dave come on dave don't
don't do him listen
the deal the deal is this man what most
people call work
in real work so stop whining
and finish your degree debt-free if you
can do that part-time that's fine
if you quit your full-time gig and your
part-time isn't enough crank it up and
take three part times and call it
full-time and get back after it
whatever it takes to get that degree
debt-free that's what you're gonna do
yeah um and so you're not at risk as
long as you're willing to work
there we go and don't listen to dave do
not work 12 hours
that's part-time anthony no whining it's
just a half a day there's 24 hours
it's only a half day work my gosh just
light weight you know in the last
segment dave you said you're going to be
here for 20 years unless you say
something
crazy i think uh unless i quit making
sure
that does make sense it's still just a
half a day i think you're down to one
year dave
i'm losing traction fast josh is in
atlanta
hey josh welcome to ramsey show
hey guys how y'all doing better than i
deserve what's up
fair enough fair enough um so little
context
i'm a new listener um and first time
homebuyer
and yeah this market as i'm sure you're
aware
it's just kicking my butt um this
morning the
real estate market yeah you know real
estate's um
you know buying a single family home
yeah um it's wild in it
yeah a little bit so my question for you
is
um you know i put a couple of offers in
you know got blown out of the water
because you know everyone right now is
thinking with their emotions so it's
like i gotta have this house and you
know they're going 20 over asking
and i'm putting offers in for five over
asking
um i guess my question is
do i restructure my
my budget for a house because i've got a
sizeable down payment
you know and luckily that makes you know
pretty decent money
how much you have down and how much you
make so i've got down about
50 to 60. good um and i make around
100 000 base good how old are you
i turned 26 this week actually good for
you you're single
yep oh well i'm gonna you know yeah yeah
you're not
are you married you're not married okay
good no i wasn't asking about your
dating life i just asked if you're
married okay
the uh uh so a single guy 26 making 100
was 60 saved
well done sir very well done no no debt
josh
no pay for car in cash you know got one
credit card just for
two percent cash back that i pay off no
club every month no student loans um
you know people sometimes yeah okay all
right
so so um what you're calling about is
down in your heart you have recognized
that people have lost their freaking
minds
absolutely and you're trying to not join
you're trying to not join the crazy
parade
please don't exactly right like i gotta
text my real estate agent today she was
like yeah they're going with another
offer yeah and she's
she's she's the drum major at the crazy
parade yeah
sure yeah she's just trying to keep all
the stuff in order here yeah well she
wants you to buy a house and if you
don't go crazy you're not gonna buy a
house right now
so here's the thing have you ever seen
one of those movies or ever been to a
live
auction where they're auctioning off
something
oh yeah like the jabbering auctioneers
yeah yeah and uh there's an old one with
the old comedian jerry lewis and uh dean
martin or something at auction and
he kept scratching his nose and
accidentally bidding and all this stuff
you know what i'm talking about
but what happens at an auction is people
get excited
and in the exuberance and the emotion of
the moment they
overpay for stuff and that really does
happen that's why it makes a great movie
scene as well
that makes sense yeah totally that's
what you're in the middle of
yeah so you need to you need to
emotionally steal yourself
put a buffer up in your emotions
psychologically
called your intellect that says i am
willing
regardless of how many crazy but people
are around me
to pay x for this house
if it goes for x plus 20 grand that is
god saying i'm not supposed to get this
house
yeah fair enough um i mean it's
it's every house though that i put in
hey
josh it's the market but you know what
you think it's gonna be every house for
a decade
no no you think it's gonna be that way
for two years no no
it might be that way till christmas it
may be next year before you buy a house
but don't get in the crazy parade
and josh why are you in a rush to get
into a house not really there's nothing
on fire here yeah
you're young you got some money yeah
i know i've been i've been dying for my
own space you know
well go get an apartment okay what are
you living at home
so yeah we're we're renting at home
right now okay um all right so
rent a home big deal don't join the
crazy parade don't do it bro
it's listen if you can buy a house and
you have done it in a way that you feel
proud about how you did it instead of
ashamed
that you joined the crazy parade then
buy a house i'm okay with that
i'm okay putting in some bids but don't
overpay i looked at a house the other
day for fun there was a million dollars
over the comps heck the dude is smoking
crack
all he's doing is fishing for the king
of the crazy parade
i'm not in the crazy parade so i just
kind of looked at him and i went dude
i'm going to stand back over here and
watch this this is spectator sport
right this is not a game i want to get
in so we'll stand back and watch and if
some idiot wants to pay that for it
that's fine but over
comps no man just calm your butt down
take a cold shower you got house fever
it's down you're gonna get a house
you're gonna be wealthy if you don't
join the crazy parade
but pay x no more
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the debt-free stage right here in the
lobby of ramsey solutions michael and
amanda
are with us hey guys how are you great
how are you
better than we deserve where do you guys
live raleigh north carolina
all right and how much debt have you
paid off 128
000 um or 128
712 ah okay and how long did this take
three years we were originally on a
four-year trajectory and
finished a year early jacked it up yes
sir cool
and your range of income during that 36
months 144 000
down to 127 000. the miss
the miss here went from full-time to
part-time all right love it
and uh what do you guys do for a living
i am a police officer and a retired
captain in the north carolina national
guard thank you for your service thank
you
oh yeah and i'm a registered nurse all
right and you work whenever you want all
you want
absolutely what a hospital in raleigh um
i actually work at wake med
it's in cary north carolina yeah yeah i
know about carrick yeah yeah my father
uh
was in fayetteville fort bragg so
familiar with fort bragg myself yes
i bet you are you know very cool what
kind of debt was this 129 000
it was uh it was everything we were
normal it was mostly school loans but uh
car payments uh credit cards and
uh 401k loans sally may took the bulk of
it though yeah
just just trucking along normal yep two
good careers but loaded up with student
loan debt and
and then other stuff starts piling in
there how long you all been married
um gosh just since 2017.
three years four years okay good yeah
funny story we um
as we were going to recon our wedding
venue we listened to your show the whole
way up it was about a four-hour trip
from raleigh to the mountains so
that's how it got started and the first
thing we did as a couple was to
was financial peace and then the rest
was history oh wow
so dope well only the military guy
recons his wedding absolutely
so romantic yeah he's just blossoming
over there yeah
that's great so you the trip though gets
you turned on to it and then you dive
into financial peace
yes sir yeah we were kind of doing our
own thing and then as soon as we were
married then we merged everything just
like you suggest and
then it was game on um we actually kind
of uh had to hit pause
a little bit about seven months in um we
found what we were expecting
yay it was a happy you know happy pause
but we did have to kind of
reign it in just a little bit for a
while there yeah very good it's a good
reason to pause
baby comes and hit play and go again and
there we go finish it up
finish it up that's a lot 129 000 is a
lot
did that feel like when you started like
you were never going to get through it
yeah
it absolutely did and um we just
continued to listen to your show i have
a
30-minute commute to my job so that's
what i did as i was
on my way in and on my way back i'd
listen to the segments so it just it
helped keep me motivated and
you know i had the spreadsheets out and
you know did all i could to keep us on
track and
we did it so i'm looking at the math
here and assuming y'all were very
aggressive
you know um especially being a newly
newlywed uh new parents what would you
say was one of the hardest things
throughout those three years
probably getting to the 129 i think it
was every time i looked at it it seemed
impossible but we for one
um she was a good support system for me
and
vice versa and we had our monthly budget
meetings and
we kept each other on track and
accountable and that that was key for us
so just trying to you know saying no
sometimes especially as a new parent you
know
in your ear the whole time you're
hearing you know you have to do this you
have to have this you have to whatever
and it's
and you don't it's okay or being
newlyweds it's like well you know we
didn't take a honey we still haven't
taken honeymoon but it's like
it'll come you know in time it'll be
fine we don't have to do anything
yeah and now you can go where you want
to go that's right absolutely
and uh how old are you two i'm 44 almost
45
and i'm 42. okay okay young people very
nice of course
you're younger than dave's that's good
very good
well you'll be honeymoon in the rest of
your life yeah very good
so um this is impressive very well i'm
proud of you guys
who were your biggest uh cheerleaders i
would have each other yeah
i was gonna say i i really do i um we
did tell people along the way i think we
got a lot of crazy looks for it
a lot of people didn't quite understand
like why don't you just keep on doing
what you're doing
you make good money you'll be fine it's
okay it's all gonna work out
exactly and and sure maybe it would
maybe it wouldn't but
um we just had to boost each other up
and just keep each other on track
primarily i think so i think we're
really each other's biggest support
system
yeah i had a crew crew at work too that
were um they weren't weren't crazy
enough to go down
the uh the baby steps road but they
helped
you know keep me motivated along the way
even though they're not doing it but
they were they were always they're at
least positive
yeah they were keeping up on what i was
doing instead of making fun of you too
yeah that's cool but now you're done so
i mean no debt this is a
how does it feel we finished up uh
new year's we were done i guess december
31
and so we made the last payment and so
to wake up on the first of the year
and say this is it like it's a new year
everything is a fresh start it was
amazing that's cool it's a great feeling
so what's next i'm curious is honeymoon
in the future or
maybe once our little guy is two so
maybe once he gets a little bit older
okay okay we might just save up and do
something even bigger than we thought
before
sure yeah we we haven't talked about it
yet we're def we're halfway through uh
baby step three and then we're
negotiating the rest of the steps and
then i think we'll get
uh aggressive about a a good good good
honeymoon so yeah
good for you guys i love you very fun so
as you're going through the 129
how much of it was sallie mae about 75
000.
a little over half that two master's
degrees in there
so at what point when you were going
through there did you kind of top
the mountain and you go ah we're gonna
make it you know that kind of that
breakthrough emotional thing
like you go over and you go yeah we got
this
i think for me i think at the halfway
point it was just like because it's that
upward upward upward climb and then once
we got to
the halfway point i was like it's
downhill from here so like 65
000. yeah and for me at least i mean
certainly there were times that were
tough after that where you were like
this is never going to end but
really and truly once you crested the
hill and you were coming down the other
side it was like
you know like the wheels came off it's
like let's go when we got through
everything that wasn't
student loans it got real to me i was
like all right this is this is serious
let's do it and then i looked down i was
like
i'm running downhill now yeah oh wow
okay
but it was still 75 000 to go yeah yeah
which is a lot
but yeah but but it's not it's not about
the math sometimes it's just the way
you're feeling about it
and you're going got it got it wow we're
doing this you know there's that moment
where you kind of break through
this is really gonna happen absolutely
this is not a theory
this is happening to me yeah it's really
there's this there's a thing that
happens somewhere in there for everyone
and it did for sharon and i too so way
to go you guys i'm so proud of you again
we've got a copy of the total money
makeover an extra copy for you to give
away
and that'll be a way to pay it forward
and help somebody else get started on
this and copy the legacy journey for you
guys
because that's the next step for you
because you got a two-year-old legacy
we're changing our family tree here
absolutely we got real reason to do all
of this very very cool so proud of y'all
thank you
well done well done thank you all right
michael and amanda raleigh north
carolina 129
000 paid off in three years making 144
to 127.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're
[Music]
dead
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been doing this a long time and
you know what the only thing i'm
positive of
if you're listening to us right now you
can do this absolutely
129 thousand dollars 28 in debt
paid off in three years if if you don't
get encouragement from that
i don't know what else can give you
encouragement but in every case it's
someone who
looked up and saw a mountain and said
okay we need a path
to the top of the mountain yeah we need
a path we need a way to get there we
need the climbing gear
we're going to learn how to do it we're
going to you know and it's always you
know we're gonna listen to podcasts
we're gonna get on the budget with every
dollar
we're gonna go through financial peace
university and ramsey plus we're gonna
read total money makeover we're gonna
read debt-free degree and send their
kids to school debt-free
in every case they got the toolbox yes
and they filled up the tools
and they said there's the mountain and
there's the path and here's the map and
let's go do it
and it's not easy nope but it's worth it
yes so and with the plan it's easier and
it's there for everyone yes sir
you i'm talking to you yeah you
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 6 34 do
not worry about tomorrow for tomorrow
will worry about itself
each day has enough trouble of its own
margaret thatcher said you may have to
fight a battle more than once to win it
now that's the truth uh some of these
battles are just what are known as
ongoing oh well
this is what happens uh better a wounded
warrior than to have never been in the
battle
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is my
co-host today jake is in san diego hi
jake welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave very excited to speak with you
i am currently 24 years old
and i just graduated from law school i
have
130 000 dollars in debt all of its
student loans
i am starting a job taking the bar in
july and starting a job
the first week of october that job is
going to allow me to refinance
through a bank at about two percent and
then
uh fixed and then on top of that i'm
gonna be making 190
000 plus bonus my question for you today
is does it make sense while i'm in baby
step two and aggressively paying down
the 130 000
to max my 401k and a health savings
account
no that's that's that's uh baby step
four
yeah well what did you what did you make
this year
this year i didn't technically work but
the firm i'm going to be working for
sent me about 40
40 000 and i had another job so it's 46
000.
so did you pay any of that on to the
student loans
i paid tuition for my final year and
before i started listening to you i
actually
funded a wrap okay okay all right so
what my challenge would be would be to
live like a college student
you know what if i woke up in your shoes
i think you have
landed an unbelievably awesome job
absolutely and you have an unbelievably
awesome future ahead of you
would you agree with that uh yes
did i understand you correctly to say at
24 years old you're going to be making
190 000
next year uh yes okay
and you owe 130 000 in student loan debt
yes you know what i would do i would
live on nothing and i would be debt-free
in one year
absolutely okay
can you stay home jake um
i can't because of where my job is but
so i'm gonna have to pay rent and stuff
um where's the truck i'm working it's
gonna be in new york city
and the hours are gonna be very long but
um
as in manhattan yeah okay
you are not gonna be debt-free in one
year you're not yeah okay
but you're going to be debt-free in two
years yeah
okay yeah you're not gonna definitely
you're not gonna you're not gonna be
able to buy housing and
you're not gonna pay for housing of any
kind in new york city and do what i was
talking about so you cannot live on
absolutely nothing but just the same
you've still landed a wonderful income
yes and congratulations you obviously
were quite a star pupil in your law
school
because you got recruited by a big time
firm that's paying you big time money
way to go i'm so proud of you yeah well
done but listen don't fall into the trap
of doing what a bunch of the goobs that
got recruited with you will do
don't do it these goobs will be in debt
for ten years because it's two percent
you don't want to pay out two percent
bull crap son pay it off now
[Music]
fast okay fast attack it bro
as fast as you can and jake this means
you you need to look for roommates
in new york you you need to really i
mean bro you are living as
cheap and as low as possible they're
going to work you 80 hours a week anyway
you're not going to have time to do
anything but work
right yeah what i'm expecting
yeah your first year out they're going
to try to kill you that's your job
yeah so yeah just just work all the time
do nothing
and pay debt and do that for a year and
a half to two years
you'll be free and all of your compadres
all of your peers will still be
struggling
with 100 to 200 to 300 000 worth of
student loan debt
and they'll all be walking around the
halls with their lips stuck out
and making a ton of money and have no
money
yeah and you son will be on your way if
you'll do what i say to do
not many people will do this but let me
tell you wealth is weird
even in the hallways of big time law
firms in new york city
wealth is weird there's a lot of people
walking around with their chest stuck
out act like they've got something and
all they got is payments
don't be one of those i want you to look
and act like you are
poor because you are you are deeply in
debt
and clean this mess up as fast as you
can
now i don't know if you'll do it or not
but man if you don't
this conversation's gonna haunt you
later sure will
it sure will man he could be free so
what a killer job
man he'll be uh he's a stud yeah and
he's a lawyer i mean
his and if he works it right dave his
income is gonna go up yeah
and he's making a 400 million dollars
with no debt no doubt
in no time at 24 years old man what was
i doing ding
ding ding ding well it wasn't law school
my show was so
and i'm so mad if it hadn't been i
wouldn't have been one of those but
anyway
i i didn't qualify for that but it's
still very cool
and the point is mathematically if you
will lean into this
he has he has a future that's so bright
susan's with us
susan's in memphis hi susan how are you
good and yourself better than i deserve
how can anthony and i help
i have a question kind of twofold i have
a daughter who came out of a four-year
undergraduate program
debt-free we were able to get our gifts
to each four kids is four years
debt-free now she's in a graduate
program in a veterinarian school
and you know welcome to adulting she
took out
loans to pay for school so after four
years of school she will be
in debt probably around 160 to 180 000
so you know as a parent of grown
children i've been really kind of
talking to her about
you know do you want to just pay some
interest off can you get in the habit of
even if it's 100
a month just just pay something off on
it to get her
to be disciplined toward that she's
asking me mom do i need to open up a
roth ira
right now with the money i get from
grandparents from just the odd jobs that
she's able to do she's very industrious
she's
already gotten a job over the summer but
i think she's a little confused about
what she needs to do first or second
while she's living on loans and just
studying you know
21 hours each semester so do you guys
have
some steps for her well
suzanne here's the thing that i really
want to challenge you on it that you may
not like
um i think but instead of for taking the
money to have your daughter pay towards
her loans i want to kind of challenge
you a little bit and suggest a different
route which is
have her take that extra money and start
paying it towards her school now
okay as far as so this way she can stop
borrowing
as much money now you're right it may
not be a whole lot but if she has an
extra 500
she needs to put that towards her school
not into a roth ira not into investments
not even
into paying off the key thing is i want
her to stop borrowing
as much money as possible and then from
there
once she graduates college then we can
have a conversation on how to start
paying off debt
but i want her to stop building up the
pal that that's the conversation
i will be having with your daughter at
this present time yeah as fast as she
can as much as she can
limit the borrowing or down to no new
borrowing
and then the next step will be to clear
the debt and the roth iras are way after
that
she does not need to worry about
investing right now she's broke yeah
and getting brokered about a minute yes
she is and she's actually going down on
her
housing by moving in with somebody else
by 500 a month so she is trying to lower
her her monthly quote installments
because she only gets a certain amount
and where
she's trying to borrow the least that
she can
but you guys would not even if it's just
a little bit of
her getting a habit okay the habit is
don't borrow more
exactly okay everyone he's wonderful
thank you yeah every one of those
dollars is avoid
going further into debt further in debt
further into debt um
because that's just the l that's less of
a mess to clean up when you get out
absolutely and um
that's where because the opposite is
what usually happens is that people just
go and borrow for everything
they buy a car they run an apartment
with a skylight at jacuzzi and
racquetball court
and it's all on government-funded
student loans
yes as if that were necessary for
education
and that she's not doing that that's
what a lot of people do right
good show anthony hey thank you dave
thank you america good job man
james childs and kelly daniels in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you